Okay back to Minnesota, that's where I practiced now, that's where I was born and raised, started
up practice again, and started doing chiropractic again, and just studying to write, actually
had the right machine that I wanted picked out and everything that I wanted, I just did
not have permission to buy it at that time, there were a lot more expensive than they are
now.
And then a patient came to me, I had a very busy practice, she was just terrified, she was,
I got to talk to you right now, okay, brought her in the room, she was, I have breast cancer,
it's the most aggressive kind that you can get, it's in both breasts and they said if I don't
do chemo and radiation, I'll be dead in three months, and I said, you're telling me this,
why?
And she said, because I don't know who else to go to, and she goes, you don't know this,
but my friend died of the chemo five months ago, I nursed her through it and it was the
worst thing I've ever seen in my life, I'm not doing it, so if you can't help me, I'd rather
die.
And I just knew, right then, you know, I don't hear the voice of God, audibly, very often,
that I admit to, but I just knew right then that I was, it's like, you're buying a rife,
I just said, char, I'm buying a rife, I know you have no idea what that is, you're just
going to go with me on this, and I need to come down three times a week and we're going
to do this on you, she lived an hour and a half for my office, she gave down three times
a week, that was 13 years ago March, she's still alive today.
And it was because of the rife, and when I, little I do, I do a lot about nutrition compared
to other doctors, but about cancer, I didn't know a lot about cancer at all, and then eventually
God said to us, another cancer patient, another cancer patient, literally, you know, five
years later, no, we're getting like two or three cancer patients, it wasn't, it was just
kind of a trickle, because God knew that I would have probably ran the other way, and then
I finally thought, oh my gosh, what if I'm doing something wrong, you know, so I went
back to school, got an AMA fellowship in functional medicine and integrative cancer therapy,
and that's the majority of what we do know.